the student debt cancellation idea was
trending online yesterday
i think because of this story here's cnn
cnbc's report
uh says in a recent interview senate
minority leader chuck schumer suggested
that president-elect joe biden
should issue significant student loan
forgiveness through an executive order
describing a possible fdr style agenda
during biden's first 100 days he said
schumer said i have a proposal with
elizabeth warren that the first fifty
thousand dollars of debt be vanquished
vanquished vanquished the debt
and one way to vanquish debt is to pay
it back
i mean you did sign on the dotted line
after all
and uh we believe that joe biden can do
that with the pen
as opposed to legislation so he could
just sign something and get rid of 50
000 of debt if you have student loan
debt that's got to be nice
schumer also mentioned policies to
address climate change wealth inequality
immigration reform criminal justice
reform
uh it's a big bold agenda he said my job
is to get as much of that pass to get
the votes for it which obviously is not
something i could snap my fingers and do
well he can't snap his fingers and do
that but he can but joe biden can
apparently snap his fingers
and make 50 000 of debt go away
which which makes you wonder well if you
could do that with student loan debt
what about my
mortgage uh what about a car loan
payment can you do that for us too
see that's that's one of the many
problems with the student
debt cancellation idea is that this is
just one
form of debt that people are dealing
with i don't i don't really
see why this should be the focus
you know if if you want to help people
financially by getting rid of debt you
can just
make make the mortgages go away
but here's here's my real problem with
the with the
whole student loan cancellation idea
well many problems with it but here's
one of them
that the people who are calling for this
you know they would respond to what i
just said a second ago about how well
you signed on the dotted line
how can you be a victim of a an
agreement
that you entered into willingly and
their response would be well these kids
were taken advantage of this was
predatory
um you know these were these were these
were kids basically they
might have been 18 years old but they're
just out of high school and
they don't understand what they're doing
and they've been
lied to they've been given false hopes
and false ideas about what the future
holds and how easy it's going to be to
pay all this back
and they don't really understand that
they're going to be paying this for two
decades or what that means for them
financially
and so they're entering into this
because they think they have no choice
and the thing is i agree that's that's
true i'm very sympathetic to that i do
think it's predatory
and i do think they're being taken
advantage of and i do think it's a scam
and i do think that a lot of these kids
are agreeing to this not really
understanding what they're doing
and they're agreeing to it they're
paying exorbitant amounts of money
for an education that simply is just not
worth it
not worth that kind of money but the
problem is
so i can agree with that but that means
we need to be having a conversation
about the university system
fundamentally
and the people calling for loan
cancellation they don't want to talk
about that
so what they really want to do is they
they they have
they have identified the beast which is
the university system taking advantage
of these kids
but rather than slay the beast they want
to keep feeding the beast
and so i just i can't take it seriously
until we're going to have a conversation
about the whole
the whole absurd idea that education
should be this expensive in the first
place
and also that every single person in the
country
needs to have what 16 years of formal
education before they can get started
living an adult life it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ludicrous and until
we're we're ready to talk about that
um this situation is not going to get
any better
you make you snap your fingers and make
the loans go away
that's not going to cause the
universities to charge less for
tuition if anything it's going to have
the opposite effect
okay number three i want to share this
with you a tweet from camila harris
it's just it's utterly terrifying but
she says
know that joe biden and i will wake up
every single day
thinking about you and your families
this is exactly the problem
this is what the left doesn't understand
i don't we don't want that
i mean i very much doubt it first of all
i don't i don't really believe it first
of all i don't believe that you're
waking up every morning thinking about
what can i do for the american people
today
but even if you are that's not what we
want
we don't want you waking up every day
thinking about what you can do for us
we want basically to be left alone as
much as possible that's what most
americans want
um all right my producer sent me this
something here from
pink news the lgbt rag so we'll see how
far
we can get through this
it says
new call of duty gives players proper
non-binary option
and the most toxic of gamers are
reacting exactly as you'd expect
the article says are you non-binary have
you always dreamt that one day you could
serve ronald reagan and join the
american military-industrial complex and
carry out war crimes
now i have dreamt i'm not non-binary but
i that is something i've dreamt about
if that sounds pretty neat to you then
now's your chance in call of duty black
ops cold war
players now have the option to in a
first for the series single-player mode
choose their gender which includes a
non-binary option
it comes after early reveals a video
game in august by publisher giant
activision revealed that users
were eager to play as imperialist war
hungry killers could list their custom
characters gender as male female or
classified
the move sparked a grab bag of reaction
from lgbt plus gamers
who uh wondered why black ops couldn't
just provide a dedicated non-binary
option
the game's creative director initially
sought to clarify during a venture beat
roundtable that okay i can't go on this
that's as far as i can go
i thought this was gonna a whole article
but this this is what people are worried
about in america now
having having non-binary options for
their video games
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt wall show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content